Jeremy Corbyn the world is going through
a terrifying public health crisis it's
now very quickly turning into a huge
economic crisis as well if things have
been different in that general election
you'd have been the man steering us
through how would you have handled it
hope we'd have started onto it more
quickly and recognized the seriousness
of it from the World Health Organization
warnings that were sent out in January
from China and recognized that the only
way you can get on top of it is by
knowing how severe it is and that means
testing the fact that we are not yet
even testing 10,000 people a day is very
very serious indeed
there are almost half a million people
working in the NHS and the care sector
even they have not yet been tested it is
ludicrous we've got to get on top of
testing so just to be clear you don't
think it's about the speed and scale of
the crisis and the growth of the
epidemic you think rather the testing
failures have been because the
government's dropped the ball it's both
it has obviously been a very fast-moving
crisis we do have to bring it under
control
testing is a very very important way of
it but also the superhuman efforts of
people throughout the NHS to free up
beds to bring staff back to bring
retired staff back and now to open three
new hospitals is wonderful and we should
applaud them but we shouldn't have had
ten years of austerity when we ended up
with 94% bed occupancy in the NHS and
obviously a difficulty in coping because
of that when Boris Johnson says as he
did in his video address that he did
last night that the ambition is to
really ramp up test and that's what
they're really doing does it irritate
you given that that's not the reality on
the ground it irritates me a great deal
when nearly three weeks ago John
Ashworth and I met him to raise these
very points with him saying the
importance of getting on top of testing
and it seemed to me that the facilities
the government to get that testing done
have simply not been effective what did
he say he would do three weeks ago he's
that at that time they were testing at
5,000 a day and it was going to increase
as quickly as possible here we are now
all these weeks later we're not even yet
reaching 10,000 a day and it's
apparently because of the shortage of
test equipment because the NHS was not
able to purchase it when he needed to
because they seemed to be running on the
idea that it wasn't necessary to test it
it is absolutely how can you possibly
have an idea of how many people have cv
unless you test well Jeremy Corbyn there
in conversation with Beth Beth Rigby who
joins us now Beth he's critical of the
government quite strongly critical of
the government the government will say
well hang on a minute
we were just acting on scientific advice
if you criticize ours you indirectly
criticized civil servants yes well I
think the point that Jeremy Corbyn was
making in that interview on testing was
that he thought it was a ludicrous
situation that the government hadn't
ramped up testing more quickly he talked
about the examples from South Korea
talked about Germany and how they had
scaled up tested and said it was a
ludicrous situation that we find
ourselves in that those frontline NHS
staff are not getting the sort of
testing that they need and we know the
issue around this many thousands of NHS
staff that should be working on the
frontline as this disease advances and
the number of cases in hospital
continues to grow they should be at work
but they're off self isolating at home
not necessarily because they're ill but
because someone in their family is and
they can't be tested now the government
has come under huge criticism for this
in the past 24 hours and I expect that
they will be kind trying to bring
forward some sort of action plan to give
some clearer answers as to how they
intend to improve that but what was
interested in that interview was Jeremy
Corbyn was very clear that three weeks
ago he had a meeting with the Prime
Minister with the shadow health
secretary John Ashworth in which the
Prime Minister talked about trying to
ramp up test and he talked about getting
to 5,000 tests a day and scaling that up
that was three weeks ago we're still in
a situation
we're we're woefully behind other
countries and we're woefully under solve
in the NHS frontline staff the other
issue in that interview of course was
the issue of austerity and Jeremy Corbyn
is stepping down as labor leader on
Saturday we sat down together we'll run
out a full interview later on it's his
final sit-down interview that he will
give as Labour leader and he also talked
about austerity about how the NHS in his
view was underprepared going into this
crisis because it had been under strain
already before this added pressure came
to it at the other point he made in the
interview was that he didn't believe
free market economics could now solve
this argument that the coronavirus
crisis has radically changed the
relationship between all of us and the
state and the relationship between the
government and the state and that those
sorts of big investment big spending
programs that labor had put forward in
the general election as ideologically
the right thing to do is now being done
out of necessity by a Conservative
government and I talked to him about
what that meant for the Labour Party and
we'll run that out later as to what he
had to say